there wasn't always as much rubbish in
and around the map anga River and that's
what locals say but the problem has
become worse and worse the garbage now
blocks the flow of the river and
pollutes the water to clean it up these
days everyone pitches in with locals
from Fort Portal in western Uganda
coming together once a month to collect
garbage as head of a local conservation
group edgar Mogens ii successfully
raised awareness of the problem to start
with he had to contend with a lot of
reluctance is the problem
damp and how within within the buffer
zones of the river even outside the
riverbed as you walk around you'd
realize waste management is still a
problem in foot patrol of as we are
doing this work we don't do it all
ourselves we involve the leadership
because they're the ones with authority
we involve the communities the quality
of the rivers water is crucial for the
region originating in the mountains it
irrigates the fields around Fort Portal
and flows until like George a regional
fishing hub
but large swaths of land along the river
have been deforested causing widespread
erosion the only intact forest left is
in the kabali National Park it's home to
some 1,400 chimpanzees making it one of
their most important habitats in Uganda
their survival depends on a functioning
clean water supply if the river is
degraded regional biodiversity will
suffer getting the general public
interested in conservation was no easy
task
most of the locals live in poverty
environmental protection has to make
economic sense if it's going to catch on
so Mugen Zi works as both
conservationist and financial adviser he
explains to locals how to save and
invest their money that is one interest
of strategy that we used it's an
interest rates' to the cognitive of
course we came and everyone was doing
his own thing so the strategy was let
them come together find a common find
the common activities together so that
they were able to bring in our other
issues like Environment Protection tree
planting Eccleston constructions but the
other thing that muslim' brings them
together is sav every Thursday locals
come together in a savings community
they pay in what they've earned and can
lend money to one another they already
have successful stories some people
borrow to go make the businesses however
small they are but they are so
meaningful and they have an impact to
manage the savings community now has 150
members and returned for their
membership privileges they take part in
garbage collection and reforestation
efforts thanks to the community some
local farmers have been able to
establish a successful second line of
business Maria Goretti big umma is a
member of the savings community who's
managed to set up a business with a loan
the mother of six used to farm a small
plot of land no she's a shop owner and
providing for her family without Mugen
Z's financial advice she would never
have taken that step I deposited 100,000
shares with the savings group and later
I was able to borrow 200,000 I used that
money to buy items for my store by
reselling them I make a profit
Mogens II collect seedlings of native
trees in the National Park which he
plants along the river as part of the
reforestation efforts he set up a
nursery where the saplings are carefully
tended for a few weeks before they're
ready to plant
moogan Z and the savings community have
planted 18,000 trees so far
local authorities provide support in the
form of funds and land today the
conservationist is on his way to give a
talk to schoolchildren ensuring a clean
water supply
keeping forests intact and preventing
ground erosion those are the
cornerstones of his message to the next
generation
[Music]
Mogens he has taken that message into 20
schools he doesn't even need to offer
these young people financial incentives
to spark their interest around 2,000 of
them along to environment clubs
he says it's much harder to convince
adults of the importance of
environmental issues than young people
he's pinning his hopes on them to make a
difference
if you want anything good
it has start with the children because
everyone's going to manage these natural
resources in the future so the moment
you start when they are still young you
inculcate that culture of environment
that culture of conservation environment
conservation when they are still young
so they will grow knowing it's very
important to particularly environment
with their help he's confident he can
reach his target in the next few years
Edgar Mogens II is hoping to plant a
million trees